the purpose of screening is to detect
cancers early and the purpose of
detecting cancers early is to try to
save lives so one of the problems with
lung cancer now is that we haven't had a
means of early detection and because of
that the majority of cancers are
diagnosed at late stage when the chance
of cure or even long-term survival is
poor and so the hope for screening for
lung cancer is that we will increase the
number of patients who are diagnosed at
early stage where we have a good chance
of curing that patient and increasing
their survival and decreasing their
mortality from lung cancer well we have
some recent evidence actually from a
very big study that shows that there's a
pretty dramatic reduction in deaths from
lung cancer with low-dose CT screening
we've been trying to develop a screening
test for lung cancer for a long time for
many decades but we finally actually
have a screening test that works this is
pretty new information and so we're just
trying to figure out how do we actually
implement this and make it work for us
the National lung screening tile the
nlst was a really big trial over 53,000
patients a really big trial used
low-dose CT screening on an annual basis
for people that are at relatively high
risk of lung cancer and found a pretty
dramatic reduction a twenty percent
reduction in lung cancer deaths for
those people that were screened on an
annual basis
the National lung screening trial is
limited to a specific population and the
criteria for entry for the study were
aged 55 to 74 years the ability to
tolerate a thoracic surgery if it were
necessary and 30 pack years of smoking
and if the individual had quit they had
to have quit within 15 years of entry
into this study so we know that the
results of the nlst are generalizable to
that population the limitations are what
about everybody else and so if an
individual does not fit into the
criteria that were used by the nlst you
really can't apply the results of the
study that twenty percent reduction in
mortality from lung cancer to them the
obvious benefit to screening is if you
can diagnose lung cancer early and
therefore treated effectively and be
able to cure it and certainly you know
lung cancer is a you know the major
cause of cancer mortality and a major
problem mainly because in many patients
we don't find it until it's very
advanced when we can't cure it you have
to remember that screening is applied to
just sort of a normal population so
people that are healthy don't have
anything wrong with them and are walking
down the street so if you do have a
problem you know it's better a different
issue one of the other problems with CT
screening is that you pick up a lot of
little findings little nodules of vast
majority of them are not lung cancer
they're just normal but you have to sort
that out and so depending on how you
sort that out you certainly could cause
problems and people that are otherwise
you know healthy and there's nothing
wrong with them
there are ten components of an ideal
lung cancer screening program they
include first a personalized risk
evaluation and clinical assessment
second counseling and education of the
screening process third discussion of
the risks and benefits of screening
fourth shared decision making to
acknowledge and individuals concerns
related to screening fifth understanding
personal fears and motivators six
smoking cessation counseling and
treatment for current smokers seventh
low-dose CT scan if indicated a low dose
CT scan interpretation by a dedicated
multi dysentery team of specialists
ninth longitudal surveillance and
follow-up according to evidence-based
practice in 10th ongoing data collection
and quality assessment to refine the
screening process the integration of all
of these components is key in delivering
appropriate screening care to those who
most benefit well screening is really an
interplay of a lot of different factors
and its process so depends on you know
what your risk of developing lung cancer
is it depends on how you interpret
findings on a CT scan remember there are
a lot of little ditzel that are nothing
that are not important that you have to
sort through it depends on what sort of
interventions you do with the things you
do need to follow up on it depends on
whether people follow up with their
screening tests it depends on an
interplay of a lot of different factors
and so it's not just one thing it's this
interplay that's the crucial part of it
as the coordinator of the year-long
screening and natural program I am
intimately involved in organizing and
managing all aspects of our program both
administrative Li and clinically I am
responsible for patients care from the
moment they contact our program
throughout their evaluation and at the
time of follow-up I make sure that the
clinical team has a working knowledge of
why the patient wants to get screened
for lung cancer and what they're
estimated lung cancer risk may be based
on various risk prediction models I
participate in the shared
decision-making process and also educate
patients and their families about the
lung cancer screening process I manage
all our community referrals for
screening and pulmonary nodule
evaluations overall I act as the
cornerstone of our team integrating
evidence-based lung cancer screening
care and pulmonary nodule evaluations
into practice smoking cessation is
included in lung scan the lung scanning
program because smoking is leading cause
of lung cancer and when people are at
the screening program it provides us
with the optimal moment to talk with
people about the importance of smoking
cessation and that it's the best thing
that they can do to help prevent lung
cancer it has been shown that it is very
effective to just do brief counseling
about smoking cessation so for
physicians to start talking with people
about smoking cessation is one of the
best things that they can do in
combination with that the second thing
would be to let them know about some of
the fda-approved medications for smoking
cessation and then the third thing would
be to get them hooked up with either a
national quit line service or in our
case we have a smoking cessation program
so getting them referred to a program
that specializes in smoking cessation so
those three things combined would be
great
the benefit of quitting smoking is that
the longer one is abstinent from smoking
the lesser their risk is for developing
a lung cancer or a smoking-related
disease there's a spectrum of risk
within the nlst and we don't really know
exactly what it means to screen people
at the low end of that spectrum or the
high end of that spectrum now when you
get on a beyond that people outside of
that risk I think that's where you know
we really don't have a lot of we don't
have data that screening is really
worthwhile on those people decision
support is a service that's available to
patients and physicians to help with
decisions that are much more complicated
the idea is to actually have
patient-centered care so patients are
able to participate in the
decision-making particularly with more
complex decisions decisions support is
important in lung cancer screening
because that the lung cancer screen in
itself is the benefits are clear for
patients that meet the the analyst he
criteria however for those patients that
don't meet nlst but you have risk
factors it's not clear whether or not
those patients will benefit from the
lung cancer screening or will they just
actually see the harms of the radiation
in those areas we have something called
decision conflict whereby we're not sure
which way the patient should proceed
this actually decision support what it
does is it explores patient's concerns
about making the decision it explores
also who's going to help them make the
decision and it allows physicians to
sort of hone in on the points that that
are sort of driving the decision and
help educate the patient so that they
can really participate and have an
informed decision
a low dose CT scan was developed
initially for screening patients looking
for nodules tumors or lung cancers in
the lung the name low-dose is probably a
misnomer as even during the period while
the low-dose lung cancer screening
trials were being conducted the dose was
decreased in terms of techniques used by
one third so it's a moving target and
probably a better term would be for this
technique that we're using in this
project to call it a screening CT or
maybe even a task-specific CT we always
want to use as little radiation as
possible but if for instance you wanted
to image the heart or you want to image
blood vessels within the thorax you
would need to use a higher dose because
the inherent difference in density or
contrast between blood vessels and
muscle for instance is much less than
the inherent difference in density
between contrast of nodules in the lung
which is the equipment of a muscle
density or us and the air in the lung so
you let you can use a much lower dose of
radiation looking for nodules in the
lungs if you want to look for other
structures in the lungs or evaluate a
different disease process such as
interstitial lung disease which can be
caused by a variety of agents but and
can cause significant disability you
would have to use a higher radiation
dose in order to delineate those fine
structures the dose equivalents are for
a chest x-ray compare it compared to a
low dose CT is about 10 chest x-rays
and a conventional or standard dose CT
is about three times higher than that or
30 chest x-rays so the doses are small
but they are different and if you're
doing a screening study if you can
decrease the dose for your specific task
as we can looking for nodules in the
lungs that decreases the risk to the
patient and increases the possible
benefits to the patient everybody is
exposed to a background of radiation for
being living in this planet when you go
to see a physician you are concerned
about either that you have a nodule or a
cancer and that's the main goal of a low
dose CT of the chest it's a screening to
do look for early cancers disease in
your chest so every time you have any
radiologic test either a chest x-ray or
a chastity you really want to see if the
disease is there so a day by day in
medical imaging you are waiting the
benefits and risks of every single
procedure not just a radiologic test but
like an invasive test when you if you
are a patient that are at risk of having
a lung cancer if you smoke and there are
several criteria student at so if you
are a high-risk patient you'll be better
off having a low dose chasity because
the benefits of doing that and detecting
our early malignancy you'll be much
higher than not doing the test and
having a lung cancer develop it and may
be dying for it or having other problems
secondary to that so you're always
waiting the risks and benefits of
radiation in any medical imaging in this
case in specific case of low-dose CT
screen if you are if it is indicated for
you so that's another point everybody
should get a lung CT screening if it is
indicated for you the benefits outweigh
the risks of a very low exposure of
radiation
again the quality depends on what
tissues you're imaging and the lungs are
very easy to image because there's soft
tissue density a nodule a tumor it's
like a piece of muscle or soft tissue
versus the air that's in the lung the
difference in those radiographic
densities or contrasts is very large so
don't need a lot of radiation to
distinguish between the two structures
the low dose is excellent for looking
for nodules and it's okay for looking at
soft tissues in the chest such as lymph
nodes or some of the cardiac structures
the problem with low dose is that it's a
very noisy kind of imaging so that its
edges are not particularly sharp when
you're trying to distinguish one soft
tissue from another and it's
particularly difficult if you're trying
to distinguish linear structures so in
the lung when you're looking for
something such as a scarring process a
linear process a fibrotic process such
as interstitial lung disease which is a
common set of lung diseases caused by
lots of different factors those are not
imaged very well with low-dose CT and
you have to use higher doses of
radiation in order to image those
structures we're not really very
interested in those structures when
we're doing screening CT we're only
interested in parenchymal nodules and
adenopathy of course when the
radiologist reviews the low-dose CT they
have to look at all those structures and
if you see something in the mediastinum
or the central part of the thorax that
you think might be abnormal then you
would use another kind of technique or a
standard dose CT to further evaluate
those structures the other thing that
low-dose CT is not as good for is
looking for what are called cysts in the
lung which is a collection of air and a
long surrounded very thin very thin wall
the air because the image is noisy it
makes imaging of the cysts difficult
again like fine linear structures so for
that again you'd use a different CT
technique so again the bottom line is
tailor your dose to what you're trying
to image and with the screening CT s the
lowest possible dose is lower than for
other tasks that CT has to accomplish so
it benefits the patient's by a lower
radiation dose and decreases the risk of
the exam our radiology department
performs all the CT scans based on the
guidelines of the american college of
radiology as a a CR accredited
institution we have to do phantom
calibration every morning so what
happens is the physicists and the
technicians go to the CT scanner and
they scan a water fence and to make sure
the quality is good that's for any CT
scan when you're talking specifically
about a low dosage screening city of the
lungs what we do is before during and
after the acquisition of the images we
perform specific quality control
procedures before we acquire the image
we make sure that the numbers the
radiation numbers that we input in the
CT scanner are adequate to provide the
lowest possible exposure to the patient
during the acquisition we make sure to
educate our text to talk to the patients
and click the right buttons so they
don't expose the patient for any more
than necessary after we acquire the
images we look at the images and make
sure there is no noise that would
preclude a diagnostic study we make sure
the quality is adequate to visualize
nodules or message within the lung
parenchyma and then we always look at
the amount of radiation that that
specific patient was exposed to to make
sure there was no mistakes so it's a
continuum effort we have the basics City
ACR guidelines that takes care of the CT
scan but for specific low-density screen
we make sure that we do a pre during and
post procedure quality control
fortunately when screening is done in
the population defined by the nlst or
actually any of the large screening
studies that have been done around the
world there's a very high likelihood
that an abnormality and specifically
small pulmonary nodules will be
identified we know that in the nlst at
the baseline study 26 to 27 percent of
the study subjects actually had at least
one pulmonary nodule identified and at
the second annual repeat another
seventeen percent of patients actually
had a new abnormality identified and so
it is very likely that a naja will be
found in a population that is screened
we know from the mail screening study
that was done about 10 to 15 years ago
that at the end of their five years of
screening and their criteria were
slightly less smoking than the nlst
seventy percent of their study
population at the end of five years had
actually had at least one abnormality
identified so unfortunately it is very
likely that another will be found if we
screen and that's why it is so important
that a comprehensive nodule program be
embedded into the screening program it
is really important that there be
adequate follow-up for any screening
study that is done because of the
likelihood that an abnormality will be
found if not at the baseline screen than
in yearly screenings thereafter and so a
comprehensive nodule program preferably
that is also part of thoracic oncology
program needs to be an integral part of
any screening program and the
implication of that is there is
expertise to determine the likelihood
that any given abnormality found on
screening is a cancer what the
appropriate follow-up should be or when
an invasive intervention is warranted
first of all there are a lot of nodules
that are benign the vast majority and
they're not lung cancer but even with
those nodules that are lung cancer there
are some that are pretty slow growing
and not aggressive and some that are
very aggressive and so you really want
to be able to kind of understand what it
is you're dealing with and kind of
tailor your interventions appropriately
to to what needs to be done for that
screening is really not just getting a
scan it's a whole process of you know
assessment of risk and then you find
little findings you have to sort through
what to do with them do you need to
biopsy do you not need to biopsy how do
you do that and so that really requires
the expertise of a lot of different
people that requires expertise of a
pulmonologist a radiologist a surgeon
and interventional person in a variety
of different people that all have their
own areas of expertise
you